Problem number six.
That's too skinny.
I want to use this tool.
Problem number six.
I had to restart my computer,
so everything got reset.
If m and k are positive, it's
fairly complicated.
And they that 10m squared k to
the negative 1 is equal to
100m, what is m to the negative
1 in terms of k?
Let's see if we can simplify
that thing I wrote at the top.
k to the negative one
is equal to 100m.
Well let's divide both sides
by 10, you get m squared.
k to the negative one-- that's
the same thing as m squared
over k-- is equal to, and we
divide the other side by ten,
is equal to 10m.
Let's divide both sides by m,
and they're positive, so we
can do that.
So it's not 0.
So you get m over k is equal
to 10, because m squared
divided by m is just 10.
m is equal to 10k.
But they don't want us to figure
out what m is in terms
of k, they want to know
m to negative one.
Well m to the negative 1 is just
1 over m, so if we just
invert both sides of this, we
know that 1 over m is equal to
1 over 10k.
That's the same thing,
of course, as m to
the negative 1.
And 1 over 10k, that's
choice D.
Problem number seven.
We are on problem number
seven, that
I will do in mauve.
Edna and Nancy leave the house
for a common friend at the
same time, and walk
for 4 hours.
4 hours is how far they walk.
Edna walks due east at
the average rate of 4
kilometers per hour.
Nancy walks due north
at an average of 3
kilometers per hour.
I'm doing this a little bit
messy, but you get the point.
Nancy's going north, Edna's
going east. What is the
straight-line distance between
them in kilometers at the end
of 4 hours?
So this is Pythagorean
theorem.
At the end of 4 hours, how far
has Edna traveled east?
They're starting at the same
point, oh I don't like that.
How far has Edna gone east?
Well, she's going to be
going 4 kilometers per
hour times 4 hours.
And that equals 16 kilometers.
That's how far Edna went
east. Now how far
did Nancy go north?
Well she went at, oh my god
I was using the line tool.
Undo.
So same thing, she went north
at 3 kilometers per
hour times 4 hours.
So she traveled 12 kilometers.
This is a Pythagorean
theorem problem.
After 4 hours, Nancy's
there, Edna's there.
And you just need to figure out
the straight-line distance
between them.
We just have to figure
out this.
And actually, a trick to this,
let's say that we want to
solve for x, you could say that
x squared is equal to 12
squared plus 16 squared.
And you could figure it out.
Or you can make the further
realization that this is
essentially a 3,
4, 5 triangle.
You could say that this is 4
times 4, this is 3 times 4, so
this side is going
to be 5 times 4.
If you remember your 3, 4, 5
triangle, Pythagorean theorem.
If you don't, just do this.
You get x squared is equal
to 144 plus 256.
So x squared is equal to
400, and then you get
x is equal to 20.
So you could do it either way,
this would have been a little
bit less math.
So x is equal to 20,
so it is choice E.
East, the other one
walks north.
This is choice E.
Problem number eight.
I'm using an old workbook that
was used by my cousin when she
was in seventh grade.
She's now in tenth grade, and
she's marked up some of these
problems. So I have a little
bit trouble reading.
And she was only in seventh
grade, but some of the
problems are circled incorrect
so that's what's making me
second guess myself every
now and then.
But anyway, back to the
problems. She now doesn't get
any problems incorrect,
back to the problem.
She's actually the reason why I
started doing this, because
I worked with her, and
she saw improvement.
And then I worked with her
brother, and they saw
improvement.
And then I said, well let me
just make a bunch of videos,
so a bunch of people can
see some improvement.
So let's see what they
have drawn here for
problem number eight.
So let me draw the x-axis.
Let me draw the y-axis.
And then they drew a parabola.
The figure above shows the graph
of a quadratic function
that has a minimum
at point 1, 1.
At the point 1 comma 1, it
has its minimum point.
Let me do that in a
different color.
That's the minimum
point there.
If f of b is equal to f of 3,
which of the following could
be the value of b?
So on the graph they drew,
if you go to 3.
1, 2, 3, and if you
just follow up.
You go to 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, so you go up 5.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, there's
a point here.
And at least this side of the
parabola, or the quadratic,
goes something like this.
I'm trying to draw as carefully
as possible.
And the other side
is symmetric.
It'll do the same thing.
And they say f of b is
equal to f of 3.
So f of 3 is here, and if you
want to get the exact number
it's f of 3 is equal to 5.
But that actually doesn't
even matter.
Because this is 1, this
is the point 1, 1.
This is the point, this
is x is equal to 3.
And the big realization is, well
this is a quadratic, this
is a parabola, this is
it's minimum point.
So it's going to be symmetric
around this point.
So if it reaches 5 here, so it
took 2 units to reach 5 going
to the right, going in the
positive x direction.
So similarly, it's going to take
2 units to reach 5 going
in the negative x direction.
So what's 2 units less than 1?
So 1, 2, you'd get
to negative 1.
So at b could be equal
Actually b would be equal
to negative 1.
So the correct answer is C.
The choice is b is equal
to negative 1.
Let's see if I can squeeze
in problem number nine.
Problem number nine.
A family of 5 is planning
a 4-day camping trip.
So 5 people times 4 days.
Each person will need 1
bottle of water for
each day of the trip.
So times 1 bottle per
day, per person.
If water is sold only in
3-bottle packages, how many
packages must the family
buy for the trip?
Well how much water
do they need?
There's 5 people, 4 days, and
they each need a bottle of
water a day.
So they need 20 bottles.
And it only comes in packages
of 3, or multiples of 3.
If they bought 6 packages it
would be 18 bottles, that's
not enough.
So they have to get
7 packages.
7 packages times 3 is equal to
21 bottles, so they have to
buy 7 packages.
Not too bad.
All right.
I'll do the next problem
in the next video.
I'll see you soon.